jetzt gerade werden mir einige sachen in
meinem leben hey leute was glaubt jetzt
willkommen bei einem neuen video und ich
muss euch heute leider enttäuschen ich
habe wieder christian dabei leute ihr
könnt ihn wahrscheinlich noch aus
irgendwelchen videos von uns früher die
wir zusammen gedreht haben
die sind echt immer gut angekommen wenn
ich heute die kommentare darunter lese
der asse um was seid ihr für zwei
abgehalten oder das mit denen das nicht
die hellste wird dass wir nicht die
hellsten kerzen am kronleuchter suchen
dann ja heute für heute haben uns
allerdings was krasses ausgesucht und
zwar habe ich euch natürlich eben mal
wieder auf snapshot gefragt wo er mir
auf jeden fall folgen müsste ich heißt
das so ist kurz eingeblendet
gailland die mädels schickt mir doch
einfach mal so offensichtliche lügen
oder einfach also lügen womit ihr uns
jungs immer anlügt und da ist wirklich
eine krasse rezensionen drauf gekommen
ich habe ihr ein iphone und das ist
abgestürzt weil so viele snaps karl dass
herr schwenker von fünf hatte welcher
weise von sechs mann iphone 6 s plus mit
720 gewollt so richtig behinderten guck
mal mama weiß nicht wieviel warum wohl
stell dir vor ich nur hier wäre eine ich
bin das hier so richtig etwas cavigelli
grad auf sylt
jetzt ist auch gut austauschen jetzt
freu mich schon wieder alle in die
kommentare wir sind nicht die hellsten
leuchten auf den kronen kerl hier ist
wie geil aber es ist wirklich cool wenn
es nicht noch mehr seite sieht weiß
längst dass man nochmal starten von den
staaten jetzt ja leute auf jeden fall
habe ich eine menge anregungen von euch
bekommen und eine menge ideen etwas
sagen warten belgrad gewechselt
junge ich schreib oft jetzt halt dein
herz immer nur reden ich will mit allem
fertig werden also leute wir haben eine
menge sachen bekommen und ich würde
sagen du darfst dir von diesen ganzen
von diesen ganz kann man hier so sieht
das aus darfst du dir einfach gleich
fünf aussuchen und die vorlese und dazu
mit einem kommentar begebe mich
verpissen mich dann so weit weg sei
ich würde sagen bei 12.000 likes gibt es
noch eine folge ist dabei die sensation
ist realistisch ist natürlich als ich
habe sonst x 104 2000 leute ich werde
mir die hatten die wieder waschen
ein gast bist musst du anfang juli war
das punkt keine ahnung
das erste beispiel mädchen lügen wenn es
darum geht welche bh-größe sie haben
jetzt ein kommentar ist ja immer das
wild in die kamera
sein wert wird ein bmw h mit geschickt
aber nur jemand warum ihr eben also
mädchen legen wenn es darum geht welche
bisher größte sie haben das kann ich mir
so erklären wenn man halt nicht so große
oberweite hat dann liegt man damit jeder
denkt ach ja doch de
das ja du kannst du weißt du was dies
komme ich damit überhaupt nicht ich
könnte es nicht sagen ob c größer ist
als der kreis größer also mädchen sagen
immer dass die scheiße aussehen obwohl
sie wissen dass sie gerade der geilste
arsch auf erden sind der geilste arsch
auf erden sind eiweiße geilsten arsch
haben ich bin der geilste angeschafft
werden
jetzt lasst mich doch mal aus reagieren
ich finde das ist ja macht ja sinn so
das mädchen das sagen weil die wollen
halt so zum beispiel mädchen sagt wir wo
ich sehe heute wieder so hässlich aus
und sie will damit bezwecken dass du
sagt eine etwa schlaf du siehst nicht
herzlich ort weiß was mein lehrer klar
richtig also mit haben wir das auch
geklärt wie sagen halt öfter mal dass
wir einen freund haben weil wir angeben
wollen was euch kommentieren dass man
sagt dass man freunde aber kein halt
sagt man doch eigentlich eher
situationen wie also wenn man an gemacht
wird oder wo bist du mir leid ich auf
mein freund kommt mal seine backen
werden gerade voll gut deine päckchen
werden gefangen habe ich auch nicht
verstehen weil ich gedacht habe er habe
auch noch nie gesagt hat meine freundin
also auch aus dem grund um anzugeben
eigentlich nicht aber ich kann das also
ist bei kaffee barcelona kellnerin
du willst ein getränk bestellen was sagt
sie
jetzt gehen sie kommt vor als würde ich
die ganze zweite anpassen
okay ich bin dran wenn mädchen nach der
trennung sagen wir können freunde
bleiben trotzdem wirst du am nächsten
tag von ihr und allen mädels gehasst
also ich dazu sagen man kann dann
vielleicht nicht sofort sagen du bist
der größte arschloch oder muss mein herr
siegele
da muss man ja erst und nach
überschlafen und was für sich klar zu
bekommen aber ich gerade gesagt du bist
der größte arschloch wirklich toll
findet nacht überschlafen am einen tag
ja notlüge genauso das recht du bist ja
welche sagen immer ja wir sind 15 oder
aber wir sind möglichkeiten einfach nur
12 13
die sieht so aus wie 12 dann sollte das
hat mir auch schon mal ein video dass
man sich manchmal als eltern ausgehen
junge aber du sagst 12 okay das
stückchen krasses beispiel ich kenne das
so wenn man so 16 17 ist und versucht in
einem club reinzukommen und dann sagt
man hätte ich gesagt natürlich der aber
nie 12 13 versuchen den äther zu sein
haben wir das gemacht
bitte beten für dich dann mit 249 alter
ich bin ich bin jetzt erst dann der
einzige der das video mal lustig macht
wechselt christian ist schon okay ich
bin dran so also wenn uns jungs fragen
auf wir zeit haben aber wir null bock
haben sagen wir immer dass es uns nicht
gut geht oder wie kopfschmerzen haben
jetzt gerade werden wir einige sachen in
meinem leben
mach ich auch wenn ich keine lust habe
kopfschmerzen budocenter dem
kopfschmerzen das nie gesagt bekommen
kommt vorbei ja okay das war's ja auch
schon du bist wie ich realisiert vor
schnellen antworten besonders wenn man
unterschiedliche interessen hat wenn man
den schwarm immer gefallen mag auf
einmal etwas was er mag
obwohl man es selber nicht machen auch
deswegen möchtest du gerne ist das
verhalten weil deinen freunden retten
welche freundin mädchen sachen sie
würden dem geschäft nicht ihrer besten
freundin schicken
aber die machen es trotzdem probiert
einfach ein bild von ihrem push-up-bh
geschickt wenn man auf dem klo sitzt und
ehrlich fragt was du gerade machst
ich sitze auf dem klo bilder fordern
kommt so einfach so eine antwort so ich
setzte auf dem klo fast schon egal ob
teams aber als junger mann das geschäft
obwohl bei dir könnte mir vorstellen
dass du dann echt sind auf dem crew auf
der toilette also leute kommen zur
letzten lüge die ich echt gut und hat
wenn der junge wissen möchte wie man ihn
ein gespeichert hat wenn er einen screen
haben will dann speichert man ihn
einfach schnell anders sein und schickt
dann den screen und sprechen ihnen dann
wiederum wenn er ganz normal heißt dann
macht man einfach so kurznamen sweety
oder so in macht an wie der namen ändern
hat den screenshot walter christ
schlingel tja leute das war's mit dem
video gelaufen natürlich erst hat euch
gefallen
dann kann christian dazu kurzzeitig zeit
ist und einfach mal mittels video
gekommen ist ist eigentlich ein
fitnessstudio
mc du wirst nur fette oder sie zu alt es
ist niemals leute wirklich gesünder
essen gegessen aber klingt ja war klar
leute bei 12.000 likes gibt es noch eine
folge ich würde sagen wir sind auf jeden
fall drin und würden auch noch zeugen
folgten mal bei instagram kris peeters
geschrieben wird müsst ihr selber
herausfinden plötzlich ein dass noch nie
angewendet natürlich früher immer immer
so und ich wünsche euch allen noch einen
wunderschönen abend und in wunderschönen
morgen und einem wunderschönen mittel
und wir freuen uns schon gewünscht schon
im januar wünscht wo weiß wer silvester
dieses eine video gemacht haben vor zwei
jahren wo wir ihn ein anruf gemacht
haben es sei nicht richtig genial
geworden das video leute schaut euch auf
jeden fall mal unsere alten videos an
die sind richtig geil aber fünfmal
irgendwo hängen ein video das silvester
war dass man ja fast ich würde euch
einlenken in der video beschreibung hard
rain habe ich liebe